this one is a digging round with the
worst Crosser I've ever seen in
competitive chemistry I love weird
setups but this one is something else
halzerk is a Norwegian CS Pro who plays
for complexity and if them all it looks
familiar you might have seen him
clicking heads at IEM katowice recently
and his preferred setup is well
unconventional my tastes are very
singular dude doesn't want the whole
monitor that he only needs some of
it he gets real close to the screen and
the rest is for checking his reflection
what the is that what is that but
it gets even better because this dude's
Crosshair is about as useful as an ice
cube in a snowstorm oh my God is that
his Crosshair he has to be trolling
please God he's dming on that cross
certainly keeping that cross here he's
like yeah bro look look at this phrase
on this thing I'm like oh my God so he
actually play with that concert for the
whole series it wasn't a troll I'm like
looking the whole time like how is he
even killing people yeah with the sick
flow and the incredible config I think
it's fair to say that I'm thoroughly
zerk pilled I'll I'll be down